have you ever heard of shopee cheeseburger?
these things are not yet so well known in germany,
but are as simple as they are ingenious.
is the good thing about this burger,
you don't have to form patties,
saves you extremely much time.
that makes these
Burgers but not exactly to worse burgers.
i would even say the opposite.
it is so similar to this shopee salad
Sandwiches.
just fry your ground beef in the pan,
n pile of cheese to go with it,
what's going wrong?
served with freshly cut tomatoes,
crisp iceberg salad,
pickled cucumbers and n few onions.
a simple sauce of ketchup,
Mayo and mustard and ready is your choppet cheeseburger.